The Flipped Classroom is a new method of teaching
that is turning the traditional classroom on its head.
Every day,
thousands of teachers deliver
the exact same lesson in class to millions of students.
Every night,
millions of students sit over the exact same homework,
trying to figure out how to solve it.
The Flipped Classroom is turning this upside down.
Traditionally students listen to lectures and take tests in class
and read textbooks and work on problem sets at home.
In flip teaching,
students first study the topic by themselves,
typically using video lessons on YouTube
and then apply the knowledge
by solving problems and doing practical work in class.
Modern schools who flipped their classroom
report many benefits:
1. It allows all students to learn at their own pace
as videos can be watched again.
2. Its more efficient,
as students enter the classroom prepared to contribute.
3. It enriches the lesson
as more time can be spent on group work and projects.
4. Doing homework in class
allows students to help each other,
which benefits both the advanced
and less advanced learners.
Flipping also brings changes for teachers.
Traditionally, teachers engage most
with the confident students who ask questions.
Flipping allows teachers to target the students
who really need help
instead of just those who are confident.
Also, instead of instructing from the front,
teachers “guide on the side”.
This allows them to work more closely
with individuals or small groups.
Teachers that are not great presenters,
can use third-party videos to explain the concept
and focus on methods of teaching that suits their style,
such as project work or experiments.
Once video lectures are made available online
teachers don’t need to give the same lecture
over and over again.
Again, they gain more time
to focus on the needs of their class.
Many scholars also argue
that the flipped classroom model
promotes equal learning opportunities
as all kids get the same attention
when doing their homework.
Currently kids with caring parents,
older siblings at home
or expensive private tutors
have a clear advantage over those who don’t.
Let us know what you think?
If you are a teacher,
tell us if this model would be possible in your classroom!
If you are a student,
let us know if you would prefer learning
in a flipped classroom!